also a florida politician facing federal
charges including sex trafficking of a
child
has agreed to cooperate with
investigators looking into related
allegations against florida congressman
matt gates
gates has not been charged with anything
and denies all allegations bill keating
is live
outside federal court in orlando hi phil
hello dana former seminole county tax
collector
joel greenberg who's described as a
wingman
of florida congressman gates he's
upstairs behind me in the federal
courthouse here in downtown orlando
finalizing his plea deal
part of the deal instead of 33 federal
charges against him
he now just has six but he's got to
plead guilty to all six
this also opens up the door that he's
going to turn state's evidence
and start providing the feds names
of other men who paid for sex including
with underage girls
greenberg is admitting to having sex
with an underage girl who was 17
several times and flying her and other
young women for hire to the bahamas
with other men where sex and drugs were
happening allegedly
including ecstasy and cocaine he now
faces a minimum of 12 years in prison
due to his cooperation his friend
pensacola congressman matt gates is
under federal investigation
as to whether he was one of those guys
gates denies everything he is adamant a
trump supporter
and this plea deal by greenberg is
viewed as not good at all for gates
here is greenberg's attorney last month
i'm sure matt gates is not feeling very
comfortable today
he said that on the day that the plea
deal was first reported
since this plea deal became known gates
has avoided questions on whether he's
potentially
implicated despite the scrutiny he
attended a rally as a featured speaker
at the villages the famous florida
retirement complex
two fridays ago and is scheduled for
another one in phoenix
this friday in a statement friday from
friends of matt gates it reads
congressman gates doesn't seem to be
named nor
referenced in mr greenberg's plea
congressman gates has never had sex with
a minor
and has never paid for sex greenberg
had been facing decades behind bars that
was all before the plea deal was reached
a spokesman for gates harlan hill says
greenberg's credibility
is in question saying he had previously
accused another man
of having sex with a minor who
apparently never
did that and was innocent and he says
adding
so is congressman gates
[Music]
okay
all right ladies and gentlemen what's
going on wayne dupree here brian smith
um
i've been looking at some information
this morning
and harlan hill is right ladies and
gentlemen
matt gates name is not
included in the plea agreement
however no name is included in the plea
agreement that i mean that they don't
have his name
in there right now he hasn't he hasn't
given up the goods yet
no no he hasn't but the crazy
the the crazy thing about this is
we talked about this a couple weeks ago
and you know we kind of brought it up
and the only reason why we're talking
about it right now is because it's news
it's the top news
going into today because honestly i want
to talk about these passports and the
rinky dink thing that is happening
with um with uh these
this mask announcement oh i'm sorry leah
bella is
uh is not is under the weather today she
called this morning
said that she was under the weather so
uh we're praying for
but we we will get to the pandemic
um the the end of the pen whatever the
hell it is now
we will get to the mass thing i
the gates thing is just blowing my mind
because yes his name isn't included but
no other name is included
in this thing right now and brian what
gets me about the whole thing
is he was up on three counts
33 now now i've seen where they put the
screws to people
now i'm not saying they're putting the
screws i don't know
but but you gotta take that 33 counts
with a grain of salt
right because the plea agreement
is bringing it down to six six real ones
you know
all i'm saying is somebody's gonna eat
those other 27.
[Laughter]
somebody got picked up right
right right something the frederick
prosecutors just don't
wipe stuff away and then it goes away
and you know you know
somebody's going to eat the other 27 and
he's going to give up the goods
i mean look dude they have him on
sex truck he was doing cryptocurren um a
cryptocurrency business inside of his
tax collector's office right right
he didn't think it's wrong with you all
right you're a tax collector
you know a little bit more about the law
than the average person when it comes to
money and taxes
when you set up a corporation if you
study corporate structuring
corporate credit and corporate banking
there's a lot of things that you can do
right and you know that if you do
something illegal
i mean they're gonna and you know where
the line it usually you know where the
line
is yeah this guy is
well you know what and that's why i
think the cryptocurrency thing comes in
with with the um with the wire because
because it's doing it is wire fraud
too which deals with the cryptocurrency
so you know
especially coming out of miami you know
man
i don't know we remember miami from the
80s man we know what you guys did down
there in the 80s
and ladies and gentlemen you're probably
saying to yourself well who the hell is
joel greenberg
he's a friend of matt gates and that's
the only reason
why you're hearing so much about it is
because he's a friend
an associate well you know they're
they're supposedly a wing
man they're throwing all these words
around you know well he's a friend right
he's a relative well he's a he's a
neighbor
you know he was something to matt gates
okay
and even though they're not coming out
what kills me is that match matt hey
matt
you might not get this i mean you might
not be watching
you might not be watching the wayne
dupree podcast right now with brian and
wayne
should be but yeah i i got something to
say to you
you need to shut your face
he got up in front of a crowd
and said uh yeah they're trying to get
me for some naughty favors
you stupid butthole
[Laughter]
you stupid egghead they're gonna use
that
against your core log they got that i
mean if that's in open public forum
naughty favors you sound like bill
clinton now
oh yeah you do and and you know what you
didn't even see that
a couple of weeks ago when you were on
tucker carlson you said no this is all
false i never heard that
nothing like this i didn't even know
that this was going on okay and now i
was like oh they're trying to get me for
naughty favor so that means something
happened
that was not that naughty favors
using words like that it's just it is so
highly inappropriate because
that just hints yeah
yeah you're with children it's it's a
hint of
somebody right naughty favors right
you're a grown-ass man you're a grown
ass man
idiots yeah favors and
he did adopt he adopted a
boy i know yeah yeah he did yeah he's
kind of
and he's not married well i mean well
it's
sort of adopted right i know something
strange about that
and kept calling him the son but the
parents reached out and said no
that's still our boy or something i
don't know i don't know i mean
everything happens down there in florida
checked out the bahamas real quick
and age of k because i'm thinking okay
they flew to the bahamas to have
sexual trysts and whatnot and drugs and
whatnot what are they
so i checked out the bahamas age of
consent for sexual
um uh relations in the bahamas
is 16 uh which is pretty much america as
well
the lowest age of consent in the world
is nigeria
which is 11 go figure um but
and i believe canada canada you're
allowed to get
married and have sexual consent at the
age of 15.
i think that's pretty messed up as well
trying to get me
but if you're going to canada for 15
year olds you got a problem
that's all i'm saying yeah i mean look
man
um greenberg admitted that he was
involved in sugar daddy relationships
in which you pay women for sex including
a minor
in whom he engaged in commercial sex
acts
uh the agreement says the greenberg
introdu you know what to
that that um that uh
that video that we just played just
while ago greenberg's
lawyer said matt gates
should be uncomfortable that's not cool
man
just here's the thing you're a lawyer
defending your client
why are you gonna bring somebody else's
name in there why are you gonna throw
that around like a rag
throwing stuff up on the wall i hope it
sticks you're threatening
you really really you should know better
as a lawyer
you really should yeah i mean the lawyer
was like
uh matt gates should be worried or
something
why what what do you i mean his name
isn't enter
what do you know matt gates is i mean um
joel greenberg's lawyer
uh the agreement also said that
greenberg introduced the minor to other
adult
men who engaged in commercial sexual
acts with the might with the
minor it didn't say miners
one miner in the middle district of
florida
the agreement does not identify the the
other adult men
but multiple sources told cbs news that
gates was one of the men
greenberg introduced her to and federal
investigators are looking
um into whether she and gates had a sex
relationship
when she was 17. um
we're gonna talk we're going to okay
okay so so
in in florida the age of uh consent
is 18 18. there's a close-in
age exemption range though
meaning if you're 16 and he's 17 or
you're 17 and he's 18 the the closeness
relationship
there's an exception for that uh but no
older than 23.
yeah he's like 17 to 23. how old is matt
oh i think he's in his 30s
look we're not saying matt gays did
anything
um but i am saying this a long
person a long time ago taught me this
you are who you
are who you hang around sorry he's 39.
yeah oh he's almost 40. the man can run
for president
and he pretty much well i mean if he was
a democrat this would be
he would be in lockstep yeah naughty
favorites homeboy
naughty freaking favorites i will never
get that out of my head every time i
look at his little nasty
that big-ass forehead he got naughty
favors naughty oh my
during tomorrow's court hearing the
judge will likely not sentence joel
greenberg right away
in part to give him time to cooperate
with the government
but under this plea agreement greenberg
faces
a minimum of 12 years in prison and
possibly more
it's not like this is something new
former seminole county tax collector
joel greenberg will wake up in jail
tomorrow morning and head over to the
federal courthouse in downtown orlando
there he's expected to plead guilty to
child
sex trafficking producing fake driver's
licenses
identity theft wire fraud related to a
cryptocurrency business he ran out of
the tax collector's office
stalking a political rival and
conspiring
against the u.s to steal federal cares
act money
if greenberg cooperates with other
federal investigations
prosecutors have agreed to drop 27
additional criminal charges
greenberg has signed court documents
acknowledging he was in sugar daddy
relationships where he paid women for
sex
but attempted to disguise the payments
as school-related expenses
using his american express account at
the tax collector's office and
personal money greenberg spent over
seventy
thousand dollars paying women for
commercial sex
including a minor under the age of 18.
records say greenberg engaged in
commercial sex acts with the minor
at least seven times while offering her
the drug
ecstasy which greenberg would take
himself as well
greenberg also introduced the minor to
other adult men
who engaged in commercial sex acts with
the minor
we will not back down and the truth will
prevail
florida congressman matt gates is under
investigation for possible sex crimes
related to the greenberg probe according
to published reports
gates has repeatedly denied any
wrongdoing the congressman
has not been charged with any crimes and
his name is never mentioned
in greenberg's written plea agreement
but
based on the congressman's relationship
with greenberg we expect tomorrow's
court hearing to get a lot of
national attention now by entering into
this plea agreement
greenberg avoids a jury trial and he
also avoids potentially many many more
years in prison had he been convicted
mike deforest news 6. somebody going
down
he's still gonna get tricked out in
prison they are gonna trick him out in
prison
and i if he spends it okay so he does 12
years
that'll be the 12 hardest years of your
life yeah yeah
because you because it if there's one
thing we know about prison
and even though we aren't in prison but
if there's one thing we know our
president
don't be lazy yeah
boy he look uh hey joe
we need that uh we need that um
we need that hallway uh mopped
officer 17 officer 18 you can go on
lunch break
no need for the cameras there's nobody
in there
you can be mopping and all of a sudden
that red light turned off
[Laughter]
the dueling banjos ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen let's
let's introduce our guest chris palumbo
he's a friend of the show uh he's a
former us capital police officer
um and he also ran for the election of
the u.s house
to represent maryland's fifth
congressional district
we're happy to have him back here once
again chris
a lot going on in the country oh there
is
okay um you know we look we
we're trying to stay above the fray
and give matt every inch of innocence
look but um and i know we're going to
talk to you about some other stuff but
uh that's good
not naughty favorites oh boy i mean you
don't get i mean
you weren't talking naughty favors for
the last couple of months and now all of
a sudden
oh they're trying to get me from not
naughty favor so i guess he's trying to
get that
out in front of what possibly could
happen
right probably yeah i i just keep
thinking back to
like spike lee always says just do the
right thing
and so in florida in florida if if she
was 17 which i think that they
mentioned that she was 16 17 in florida
you cannot be
older than 23 with a 17 year old that's
considered minor that's off limits
that's
that's bad you're 40. i remember being
40. that was just a couple years ago
there's no way i can look at a teenager
like that
yeah yeah hey look look there's no way i
would look at one like that
and there's no way that i would want one
to look at my daughters
like that because if i see somebody
looking them up and down
then i stand in front of that lotum line
of sight i'm like
what is it what she got some lint on her
something like that
what's going on yeah you know no
um the pet chris the pen
well it's supposed to be the pandemic is
supposed to be over
pandering is supposed to be over cdc
came out
thursday friday thursday night friday
and said guess what
you don't have to wear any mask
that just blew everything up it blew
everything up because
so many people that don't have a vaccine
well actually
if you have the vaccine you don't have
to wear the mask
but they just left it out there like
that they didn't say anything else
so individuals that didn't get the
vaccine
are going to go around and say i did i
got their magazine
which i thought more and more over the
weekend i was like
i know what y'all are doing y'all are
going to force
code passports on people
or they're going to make the people who
didn't
get the vaccine you have to wear a mask
and now you're going to be shunned
and attacked possibly attacked by people
because
you're making everything unsafe a tax
could go up right chris am i right
i mean it's creating discrimination and
it's gonna create a cast system in our
society where
we're you're gonna have one group of
individuals who had the vaccine versus
those who didn't they're gonna be
like you said they're gonna be shunned
they'd be outcasted they're gonna be
subjugated to
criticism based on their medical freedom
their choice
um and as you said i mean earlier you
know florida and texas broke the cdc in
belgium
with them coming out back and was it
march 10th was when texas opened up
you saw the screen the texas rangers
fully packed
and they've been like ever since and i
believe it's been weeks since
unfortunately they haven't had anybody
pass away with kovy
that's a good thing it's a good thing
that we're making progress from getting
back to normalcy
um but yeah i mean even right here in
maryland and i'm sure you know wayne you
know governor hogan came out this past
weekend he just said and he said if
you and if you aren't vaccinated you
should
like you just recommended it so luckily
a lot of the local businesses at least
down my way this past weekend local
businesses
that what's up to themselves or the
person on social media saying hey we're
not enforcing mass made dates anymore
it's up to you it's of your freedom what
you choose to do
and uh that's how it should be when
you're speaking about freedoms
i i would like to be allowed to freely
speak in in question authority
question uh the vaccines when we're
seeing
uh famous people now lamenting and eric
clapton
literally uh terrified for a couple of
weeks thinking he never played the
guitar again because
the vaccine he talked um and now
apparently i'm i'm on a slight
suspension
on the tiki talks i can no longer
upload anything because uh i
posted question people questioning
the vaccine yeah what's frustrating
what wayne said earlier about the
vaccine passports
i mean the writings on the wall and i
discussed about this last year and i had
people
it was when the contact tracing bill
came out in the house and i was
discussing it back then saying this is a
slippery slope when you have this app on
your phone your mobile device is
constantly tracking your information and
data
it's picking your location it's thinking
what you're doing on other apps and you
can share that information we already
have an issue with big data as it is
so now you're giving that much power
control to corporations
and the government to know what you're
doing where you're going
uh and and i even said back then it's
creating a slippery slope
to a totalitarian society like china has
set up with their social credit scores
and it's something that you know if you
embrace and love your freedoms
we have to push back against this it's
almost like it's almost like the
government leaders
haven't stopped trying to
increase the control that they
found last year
with the lockdown i mean it's almost
like kidney
in a candy store because they didn't
realize
that well they probably wished and
wished and hoped that they could
get that type of control over the
american people like that
but when they finally got it and then
they finally realized well you know what
no matter what the federal government
says we can do whatever we want to in
the state
you know and then when that started
happening
and many other people started to rebel
so okay well we'll just we'll just
arrest y'all or
uh i tell you what we'll open back up
places but if you don't have a vaccine
you can't go in
or we won't hire you or
you know or you won't be able to go to
the store and get anything to
to eat unless you got the vaccine and i
mean honestly
things you know how the old saying
things are not going to get better
until they get worse or things are going
to get worse before they get better
i don't know if things are going to get
better right now because of
the the tract that they are on now
uh fauci said that the cdc supposed to
be coming out with
uh a bigger announcement on on the mass
but that only tells you about the
incompetence of
what happened before the weekend for
them just to put that out there and for
people
all weekend long well there we go or
i ain't got nothing i'm going out and do
whatever i want to do
i don't know but what's interesting is
that
you have like you said this whole past
year we've seen
power being given to unelected officials
and bureaucrats
who they're unaccountable and they've
been making decisions on behalf of
everybody else and who do you question
who
like you said we should always be able
to question that authority and
that that the power like it's out of the
bag right now so we gotta
be able to find a way to get that stuff
back in and have control of it um
but but that's that's interesting thing
too talking about without you how they
just released the mass mandates what's
interesting with that is you saw
you know senator rand paul i think was
the day before when he was
over about the funding for the the lab
league hypothesis
excuse me that came out and and it makes
you wonder it's like are they going are
they backtracking
we're getting caught up or something all
right let's let's get something else out
there let's let's lower the mass
mandates um but yeah it's really
interesting timing with that
yeah because now we're starting to see
that uh maybe this was
possibly i mean can we question it was
this a bio weapon
was this engineered was was this bought
and paid for by the obama administer
administration back in the day did they
know about these things coming up
now we're starting to i think it's uh if
you hit the google
sars 2025 2028 apparently there's
another pandemic
on the horizon possibly that that
that they're going to do again and as
you're talking about the power grab here
on the west side of cincinnati
um the day that they shut everything
down in march
last year they told this bar black owned
bar
you will shut down and they gave them
three days
sunday night came and they were still in
the bar they were still partying
monday morning they threw them all out
and they took
concrete screws and giant chunks of
plywood and they drilled the plywood
with concrete screws
into the face of the building covering
up all the glass and covering up the
doors
and saying that this is off limits
whatever
stickers and every business crap their
pants that night
they say i don't want that
yeah and you look at examples like in
canada you see the
the pastor at the church who defied
their lock down and said no i'm still
gonna have
a church we have people in church and
they shut them down and now
his his own home is being harassed uh
it's been egged it's been it's been
destroyed it's been vandalized
um but you look across the country of
other of other
nations that have imposed such lockdowns
and don't have the freedoms like we do
like in australia i remember there was
uh like this past year there was a there
was a there's a mother who
posted on facebook she wanted to have a
protest against the lockdowns in the
mandates
and because of her post on social media
and they don't have the freedom of
freedom of speech as we do
here they when they arrested her in her
home and took her laptop
just complete disregard for for rights
and but
that's again here in america we have to
embrace those rights
um because we lose them we're gone i
mean that's one of the great things
about living in this country if we have
those and that's what scares me with
again with this vaccine passport if that
is
implemented you have that thing the
third party doctrine
uh that came out in the 70s and it
basically says that you know those those
companies who make who are making these
apps it's going to make them so powerful
because they're holding their store and
all this data
of of what vaccines we had our medical
history
whatever history we have on our phone
that they're able to track and collect
and they're able to sell that and profit
off that however they want
but that third party doctrine says that
if the government ever wants to go and
question you
they don't necessarily need to get a
warrant anymore they can use that
company through the third party doctrine
wow hey you own that data now on them
we want to get to find information on
them without getting reward that is
scary stuff
it is it is it is and watching and
watching how
uh the media
i mean honestly in the old days the old
days before
before before me um
you would have journalists out there
trying to break the story and try and
and trying to expo not all but you have
some
that would be trying to expose what's
what's going on
to at least say okay this is not what it
seems and this is where
it goes and people will be reading the
newspaper and say okay now
we're we're walk to this but it seemed
like many people
in today's world they just want to find
the information or no actually they're
more comfortable with just
going along with whatever they see
you know or finding something that's
going to justify
whatever they were doing and going along
with that
there's just too many avenues and it
chris brown it goes back to last year is
too many avenues too many people
saying so so many different things
that the american people is confused and
when america gets
confused on the different points of how
things are
they turn things off they turn things
off and then they decide okay
you know what forget it i'll just let me
see how many songs are in my playlist
and let me get my earphones on and you
know i'm just gonna walk up and down the
street
talking to myself you know i mean that
the electorate is so turned off to so
many things
including like the matt gates thing and
stuff but the but they're so
turned off that they don't see
the decline of freedoms
or different things like that i'm gonna
throw something
to both y'all that i was thinking over
the weekend as long as you have
this
the talk of keeping freedoms in liberty
is just a dream
because covet
passports or
the way that google or facebook or
twitter collects data on you
and then they're able to give it to uh
the government anytime you don't have
any i mean
you can go around saying yeah afraid of
it but you don't have it
if you are stuck on
these things you don't have your
freedoms
am i right yeah you're like you're like
a trapped rat
you're running around in this maze
thinking you're free but
in reality you're stuck inside that maze
you you can't you can't get out and if
you try and break out or if you try and
say something or try and do something
uh wait till you get harassed wait you
get shut down wait you get kicked off of
social media
now i know there's a handful of people
that that we know
personally that have been unpersoned
forever
but you might disagree with what she did
and what she said or what he did
and what he said you might disagree with
it might disagree about how they went
about it
but the fact is that they've been
unpersoned
they could do that to anybody and again
like trump used to say
they're doing this to the president
united states of america
imagine what's it going to do to you you
know what chris chris before
before before you respond to that um i
know where i was going with this too
was i was watching a video where
um over the weekend about facial
recognition
i don't know if y'all remember the
facial recognition thing that was going
on in congress
um i was watching this documentary
over the weekend where uh this young
girl
spoke before congress and i mean
honestly it really looked like
both sides were listening to what she
had to say
because you had jim jordan questioning
you had alc
question they both sound like they were
worried about the facial recognition
thing
they were they they the fbi and all them
they were able to implement the
facial recognition without asking
anybody anything
they weren't elected to do it but they
were allowed to do it
and they were mirroring what would what
china and then was doing
okay so so now you now they say
that they're banning or they're going to
ban these things but how do we know that
they're banning these things
i mean they were bringing up people with
their face
you might have charges you might be late
on your rent you might be this and that
that's just too much information based
on your facial recognition
man it you know when um uh
and and say that they implement that
with the body cams when they pull you
over
they know exactly everything about you
without even going back to the
thing to check it out they got
everything on you right there
that's not freedom that that's dude
that's slavery in his worst way
january 6 they were doing that to find
people at their homes
you know the day of insurrection you
know and they're hunting these people
down
apparently they're able to find people
that were welcomed into the capital by
capitol police uh but but you can't find
anybody antifa you can't fight
can't find the people that terrorize uh
americans but but you can find
people from january 6th and i just
it goes back to the famous quote from
white eisenhower that we're always at a
risk of misplaced power
and what's going on right now when you
see especially you talking about social
media going back what brian was saying
there was a point when i was thinking
about just getting rid of it all
together but before my campaign in 2020
i decided well i gotta get my name out
there which is
glad i didn't because with coven and
everything shut down there's no other
outlet to get the message out
um but but what's interesting with that
is that you have that pendulum swinging
with that misplaced power it can go the
other way
and in again that's where i think it
comes down to the basic
foundation of protecting our rights and
liberties for everybody
even if you have different opinions than
us i'm still going to fight for those
you know to the end of times in the same
in the same documentary they were
talking about facebook how
the 2016 election was won by 100 000
votes or whatnot um
they said all facebook has to do i mean
now
facebook came out after that and
explained what they
are doing and how they're doing it
[Music]
the threat of what facebook is right now
is
all they have to do from their
headquarters
is set up uh
these campaigns from facebook set up
these campaigns
individually six hundred thousand people
and they can swing an election just like
that
if they wanted to remember back in uh i
think it was like 2011 2012 they had the
whole fight coney
the the the the guy from um i can't
remember where exactly in africa but
there was a huge campaign
like fight coney bring him down like
this guy's he's creating terror he's
he's uh stealing young girls from
different tribes in africa
and it was a huge social media campaign
push we'll come to find out
the two individuals i think from germany
that they they were paid
to put that together and produce it and
push it out there to see how far and
wide
this campaign would go and even those
two gentlemen from germany they had
their documentation this is a
psychological project that they were
testing
and it it it went viral instantly to
where everybody was posting on it just
nearly like the black squares that they
had last year um
everybody was posting to to go fight
coney go get them and
uh they've been working on things like
that since then and with their algorithm
and their alley that they're using
uh they're creating their own realities
for everybody else as you're going on
social media based on what they think
that you like what you see and it's easy
to get caught up in those echo chambers
too
right they're convinced that they can
absolutely sway
bare minimum moderates people that are
middle down the road
they can sway your vote into voting the
way they they
they want you to vote based on what they
put in front of you
while you're on your social media
platform they know who you are they know
where you are they know what you're
looking at and they just start popping
the stuff
up in front of you now it's it's
absolutely horrible but
we talked about this last week but these
these stupid republicans
and i'm real on both democrats but these
stupid republicans who think that
they're going to do something against
the zuckerbergs of the world
now you had a president
he cared about america more than any
president i think we ever known
and you had the opportunity don't don't
lie to me you bastards
don't make me think you got my back
cause you don't yeah yeah
i mean they're coming out with all this
legislation that
they know are isn't going to get passed
because they aren't empowered to do it
when they were in power they didn't come
up with the legislation it it's almost
like obamacare
when when obama was in office oh they
had all the obama replacements that they
wanted in unanimous votes to get it done
yep when trump got in hey um you know
that unanimous legislation y'all had and
stuff give it to me i'll sign it
well uh we can't find it
[Music]
[Applause]
we gotta rewrite it but uh we'll give it
to you
and they do that all the time all the
time
it's like i mean it's it's almost like
they're
they're uh they're dangling that carrot
you know how we always say um the
democrats dangle the carrot
for their voters so every election time
uh we're going to do this we're going to
do that we're going to do that
and then when they get the vote then
when they get elected
you know well we got to spend money in
on it republicans doing the same thing
to republican voters yeah we're gonna
man we're gonna hold the democrats
kind of we're gonna do this we and then
when they get in there
we we gotta spend a trillion dollar
omnibus bill and we gotta
fund the enrichment uh the kennedy
center uh with our good compadres over
here at the democrat party yeah
they're like oh man you know well
and yet they they'll tote on their
campaign trail if they're for fiscal
responsibility physical conservatism
they can't even spell this
yeah spence spend they can't even spell
fiscal risk
and you would expect or you would think
that these people would treat america
like they treat their own households
you ain't got the money don't spend it
honey we need to cut
cut some of the spending that it is in
dc
treat america like you treat your own
household but they get up there and
they're like crack addicts man i mean oh
well
millions have become billions they have
become trillion
trillions are like 50 cents to them now
they just throw that thing out there
like well you know we just throw a
trillion dollar thing
and it's all paid for pete budacheck
last week
said that uh biden's infrastructure bill
is already paid for
he said we got the money we got a
million dollars 14 dollars already to
pay for it
he argued we are we got the money
already
yeah and people are gonna yeah people
are gonna wonder why why is a loaf of
bread fifteen dollars
when you when you pump four trillion
dollars out of the treasure out of
treasury in the federal reserve to go
back into the system
that's what's gonna happen right and i'm
hearing uh
different articles that i'm reading and
different people that are talking about
our food chain supply issues that are
coming up now because of the whole year
lockdown
restaurants that couldn't get or
couldn't open that weren't purchasing
uh farmers that were having to dump
millions of dollars with the food and
and vats and holes and just literally
get rid of everything
now all of a sudden the beef that they
were having to sell and get rid of all
that
because the restaurants from buying it
now they're all of a sudden they're
now having to re-grow the cows and
things and now we got this giant
log jam and we got by and spend
trillions of dollars
yeah there ain't no way and
and still adding chris you got you got
money
coming in july in two months
i heard i heard this commercial i heard
this commercial over the weekend
where they thought that they were giving
advice
to people that were getting extra money
for their kids
starting in july they said what
uh what we really need is for those that
are
going to get the extra money think about
your rent first
think about think about the food in your
house
think about these things that need that
you need to take care of your house
the second thing you need to think about
is
what you need to buy for your children
to make sure that they're okay and then
the third thing is to invest
savings savings and invest it's like
but but the money that
first off not one thing on that
commercial
told them they would have to pay taxes
on it
when taxes come around next year now
not one thing and then the second thing
was
that money that you are getting you can
smile all you want to
but somebody's gotta pay that money back
that money
is is is is is monopoly plato money
actually
you know it's your it's your own money
to begin with for the most part
i i mean all this tax no no no it's
somebody else's money
i mean if you pay taxes in the past it's
a little bit of your money you know
whether you're you're purchasing tax you
know your tax at the store at the gas
station
whatever the taxes are the taxes it's
tactically it's we the people
it's it's y'all making us think
that you're giving us something that you
have well you stole it you took it from
us to begin with
and now you're trying to redistribute it
and give it back out
just don't work that way nancy pelosi
saying that unemployment insurance the
greatest thing
to help boost an economy crazy old bat
this is the ron paul this is the ron
paul side of me coming out but it's
it's with these kind of policies and the
spending
it it only hurts the middle and lower
class even more because
the rich are getting richer the poor
getting poorer small businesses are
getting shut down left and right and
they're hurting to get back meanwhile
the big companies big box stores are
profiting
record numbers right now it's horrible
policies that's that's greatly affecting
those who need it the most
and when you're saying about businesses
shut down i just want everybody to know
and look around your cities and as you
drive around
all the black owned businesses whether
it be the nail salons the hair salons
the barber salons
all those businesses were shut the hell
down and gone out of business
there's a girl a woman who opened up her
own
restaurant called christine's on the
west side it was phenomenal
i mean it went through the roof
everybody loved it she was the first
time she ever started her own business
or family involved and everything
and then doors is closed they're no
longer in business
thank you walmart's got it good
you know home depots lowe's everybody
kroger i mean all the
they got it good they're all right sam's
club whatever
i'm just saying
this is this is the heart and soul of
america to start your own business and
and to really get a piece of that pie
and they they just damn near took the
pie away to say ain't nothing left for
y'all
well you can't start a business when
people don't want to go back to work
administration they're talking about uh
another 1.8 trillion dollar stimulus
package that they're going to try to get
congress to push out
told you it's happening it's going to be
perpetual cycle
until people stand up and say enough's
enough and and
and two things chris i
i suggested or i predicted that there
would be another stimulus package before
october
uh and that might lead into november
but it's almost it's almost like a
government program now
it's almost like a government program
where
it looks like they might even
streamline it to one a quarter they
might
i don't know i mean that that's where uh
because
um aoc and the squad and all those
people they were talking about
monthly stimulus checks you know
almost even if you're not working you're
getting a stimulus check from the
government
monthly but these things look like
sooner or later it's going to be one
every couple of quarters or one every
quarter but i was like
if you stop this then the people
are going to go nuts
so you have to keep this going you know
like with biden saying
well uh your checks are going to stop
coming
if you are not seeking gainful
employment where how well how are you
going to put that in place
how are you going to put the get uh
because uh
like like brian said you know you can
call
are you seeking game yeah
[Music]
a lot of the local business gameplay
here uh a lot of them have science like
help wanted jobs opening and they said
we can't we can't hire right now because
nobody wants to work
but that's an interesting thing too if
they're going to have this continual
stimulus
pumping out and giving people their own
tax paying dollars back
and and and continue with pumping the
federal reserve and treasury department
to produce
money to flow back into the system well
that thousand dollar check that they
would have gotten
months ago and get it again its value is
going to decrease greatly because of
inflation
and you got to pay still you got to pay
taxes on it you yes
or if you're not paying tax like what
happened to me this past year
i didn't qualify or they took away
some of my my my credits my my child
credits
matter of fact i got hit for a thousand
dollars that they took away from me said
that my wife doesn't qualify
i don't know why she don't qualify she
has every year beforehand
why not now yeah i don't know
uh real quick before before i let you go
chris thank you for
um staying on the extended yeah it's a
great chat with you guys i love it
and we do this often yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
uh yeah um it turns out that
israel took down a building
that had the ap and hamas in it but
no um ap and um al jazeera
al jazeera yeah whoops um
but uh israel's prime minister like yeah
but uh
it was a it was a good takedown because
we had
intelligence that hamas was in the
building too
uh now the ap staffers
and everybody was evacuated because they
were all notified
an hour before it happened so uh
i don't know why people are so angry but
this is what bibi had it's been five
days since
hamas brazenly fired rockets of
jerusalem
and other israeli cities in a totally
unprovoked attack
this past week millions of israelis were
forced into bomb shelters
as missiles rained down on our cities
several israelis have been killed many
more have been wounded
you know and i know no country would
tolerate this
israel will not tolerate this israel has
responded forcefully to these attacks
and we will continue to respond
forcefully until the security of our
people
is reinstated and restored
we've eliminated dozens of hamas
terrorists and taken
out hundreds of terrorist sites
including missile launchers and
buildings
that hamas used to plan and perpetrate
these attacks
two nights ago israel also seriously
degraded
the terror infrastructure of hamas we
knocked out
part of the vast subterranean tunnel
network that hamas
uses to attack israel i want to remind
the world
that in firing on our cities hamas is
committing
a double war crime they're targeting our
civilians
and hiding behind palestinian civilians
effectively
using them as human shields
as always israel is doing everything
possible to protect our civilians
and keep palestinian civilians out of
harm's way
we demonstrated this yet again today
when we warned civilians to vacate the
building
used by the hamas terror intelligence
they vacated the premises
before the target was destroyed and
that's why you don't hear of casualties
from these collapsing terror towers
because we take special care to avoid
these civilian casualties exactly the
opposite of hamas
defeating hamas does not only serve
israel's interest
it serves the interests of all those who
seek peace stability security
in the middle east i want to thank
israel's many friends in the
international community
who have strongly backed israel's action
in defending ourselves
i want to thank the president of the
united states joe biden
and i want to thank the many countries
including european countries
that flew the israeli flag in solidarity
on their government buildings
no one should have any equivocation
about the choice that is so clear here
and i want to thank president biden
for his clear and unequivocal support
you cannot
equate a democracy that values life
with a terror organization that
glorifies death
i also want to say a word about the
violence we've seen in recent days
within israeli towns from low to battyam
from akko to haifa the jewish state will
not tolerate pogroms against our
citizens
we will not allow our jewish citizens to
be lynched
or to live in fear of murderous arab
gangs
we will not tolerate the torching of
synagogues and the torching of property
at the same time we will not allow jews
to take the law into their own hands
and attack innocent arabs or lynch an
innocent arab there was one such case
such effort we won't allow these attacks
on innocent civilians arabs and jews
alike
to tolerate this unacceptable
vigilantism and violence
is to pave a way to anarchy israel is
the jewish and democratic state
where all our citizens jews arabs and
everyone else
are equal before the law and will
receive equal protection from those
who enforce the law i am fully confident
that israel will be able to deal with
these threats from without
and these threats from within i'm
confident in our army
i'm confident in our police and above
all
i'm confident in the resolve and
determination
of the people of israel
you know um i i
i never thought i would see so many
people side with
palestine on uh through social media
uh many people
won't accept the fact chris that
hamas fired rockets into israel to begin
this whole thing
they they won't accept that
there there's always a starting point
and usually people miss out on the
starting point and see the second
it's almost like what happened with uh
on the towers uh
with 911. nobody really saw the first
hit even though we saw the first hit
later on video
nobody saw the first hit but everybody
saw the second hit
many people that are championing
palestine and said yeah about
it all people died in palestine and
stuff
israel is defending itself chris real
quick
yeah i think it's i mean it goes back to
i mean the peace that we've had at least
the last past four years we had abraham
accord we had all these other things
going on piece of the prize we got to
fight
towards getting that back to destabilize
that that region
and uh yeah we have unprovoked attacks
like that it's it's
very unfortunate and you know with any
country that has that against them they
have the right to do so
but uh but yeah we got to get back in in
working it for
you know like i said peace is the prize
and we got we to fight and strive for
that
right yeah uh you find out
who the bad guys really are um i still
uh
contend that that iran is funding the
terrorists
uh all the way through in order to
remove israel from the face of the earth
if you said that at any other time and
any other person any other place if you
ever said
remove an entire race of people off the
entire earth
there would be a lot of problems i mean
hitler did it back in 33.
and now y'all ain't got a problem
with the palestinians trying to wipe the
and they gave you back the gaza strip
they gave you back land they
gave you and they keep capitulating to
you guys and it's never enough for the
bullies it's never enough so
stand your ground ladies and gentlemen
we got to get ready to go
uh but we want to thank everybody for
tuning into the show
uh keep on keep keep on keeping on we
thank you
for uh for um supporting us chris you
have any last words real quick
i just appreciate the time always great
chat with you too and uh still looking
to come up to baltimore
we'll catch up for lunch soon there we
go there you go me
i guess uh coven is uh is
june 2nd um coven
retreats to the shadows and no longer
is uh a threat in the great state of
ohio
june 2 that uh 9 a.m
we're allowed to uh to rip the mask off
your face because
june 1st that son of a gun is still
there
all right job make sure make sure you
share the show
and also uh make sure that
you pray for the country because we're
really going through something we're
really going through
y'all have a great day
[Music]
work
okay